كانت تقسيم تنهج اكثر انظمه الاغلاق
والاختبارات المكثفه صرامه في العالم فيما
يخص كرهنا لكن
فجاه ودون سابق انذار بدات بتخفيف القيود
مع تاكيد نيه رفعها بالكامل في الثامن من
يناير المقبل لكن
التصريحات الرسميه المتماسكه بصفر كوفيت
تتعارض مع واقع المستشفيات على الارض اما
التحقق من انتشار الفايروس وشده فبات اكثر
صعوبه مع توقف بكين عن نشر ارقام الحالات
اليوميه وانهاء الاختبارات توقف العد صعب
من مهام صعب من مهام منظمه الصحه العالميه
لتقدير خطوره الوضع الوبائي في الصين
سيامه وانه من اجل اجراء تقييم شامل
للمخاطر تحتاج الصحه العالميه الى معلومات
اكثر تفصيلا عن شده المرض اعداد الاصابات
والوفيات وايضا حالات الطفارات
الصيني هذا اثار ايضا مخاوف عالميه بشان
احتمال وجود متغيرات جديده خارجه حدود
الصين واليابان والهند وانضمت اليهم مثلا
امريكا من بين الدول التي اتخذ التدابير
لمنع تدفق الحاله ايضا المخاوف تكبر بشان
احتمال وجود متغيرات جديده من الفايروس قد
تتسرب من القادمين من الصين وهوما قد لا
تستجيب له لقاحات كرونا الموجوده على
الارض حاليا
[موسيقى]